bonjour bonjour comment ça va vous avez
à dire un basketteur un basketteur d'un
médecin basketteurs quand même
aujourd'hui on en parle et de quoi on va
parler des commentaires youtube il ya
presque un mois faisait une vidéo que ça
peut influer de tubes on parlait de
l'espace côté youtube qui était
totalement polluée par diverses choses
va pas revenir là dessus un jour j'ai de
grandes aussi sur ce quiz noah joue la
carte du monde adore regarder dans son
jacuzzi avec la personne la plus belle
ouvrage est quelqu'un ça suffit lien
aujourd'hui nous allons voir ensemble si
ça marchait si les stress monte à re
devenu un espace cool sommes nous dans
une nouvelle ère dans une sixième
république c'est maintenant que ça
commence au royal jean galle
elle c'est parti on va dire tout ça
j'espère ne pas voir de live de m6 du
bidule ça mais j'ai eu des échos et
apparemment c'est bien mieux qu'avant
rien tout de suite la dernière vidéo
squeeze des à respecter tu as mis ton
paulo dans ton short en plus tu as
laissé l'étiquette d'achat taqwa contre
des gens qui mettent les choses dans
leur jean à thème pas les années 80 aux
potes a choisi à la souris sur l'écran
c'est vrai c'est vrai ce ci est
extrêmement holla holla mind phoque
magnifique double sous il dans la vidéo
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe j'avoue des
fois je fais pas attention et le
logiciel capture mon curseur parce que
vous stresse énormément comme actuelle
tu fais exprès regarder les étiquettes
sur les vêtements ou tu oublies dans
toutes les vidéos c'est pour se faire
rembourser après alors déjà déjà soit
clair j'ai l'air d'avoir des magasins ce
t-shirt non pourquoi je fais ça aurait
dû signer ce mystère tout de suite les
casquettes américaines la mode c'est
quoi c'est quoi c'est la mode les gars
c'est la mode débat pourquoi le boulot à
14 chez décathlon ont fait pas pareil
c'est juste la mode les gains désolé si
vous n'êtes pas la mode désolé il a
acheté une tenue pour une seule vidéo
[ __ ] holla holla je suis un
professionnel au ping pong j'avais déjà
une tenue garçon et je peux dire que
j'ai gagné les plus grands championnats
du monde dans cette tenue mais squeeze
comment tu connais la position
grenouille
c'est une technique légendaire enseigne
à nos ancêtres qui n'a dès lors jamais
été révélée commence à me faire peur
squeeze roches michael débat alors un
coup droit avec la main gauche d'accord
squeeze non ballester vais je te revois
ce screen il est pour toi mais le dans
une compil je sais pas le un coup droit
mon gars c'est quand c'est la paume de
la main qui envoie la balle c'est pas un
coup droit puisque tu l'envoies homme
est assez drôle assez franchement c'est
mignon ça fait penser à moi jusqu'à
l'âge de 15 ans qui pensait que l'on
disait cyr humaine et pas cérumen
insurgés d'après certains d'entre vous
faites un jour plus tard tes bras sur
aussi gros que tes cuisses
mdr ça te fait rire ça de faire il doit
prendre ça pour un compliment
mdr on dirait un tshirt d'employés dont
mecs que je me disais pas tant je crois
que ton vrai mec c'est cher des gens qui
travaillent au mcdo voilà non ça se fait
déjà cruellement
comment as tu apportes gens qui
travaillent au mcdo jure ça c'est
n'importe quoi j'ai plus souvent
macabres à ce moment-là attend tenue
fast food
voilà voilà un big mac et une grande
frite au nom du bourg et des gâteaux jus
alors ayons fast food qui valent était
black personne ben alors où est passé le
yacht tout le monde sait squeeze
bachelet
je les prix comme ça je les pose est là
missile destiné à lorient b s'il
électricité mais s'ils cassent explosion
work with a pris de la barre mais il a
perdu des cheveux
alors c'est quoi fêter dans la plaie
merde désolé j'ai mal posée la prothèse
du coup tu t'es fait griller non je ne
veux pas qu'à baisser
c'est vrai attends j'ai vraiment perdu
des choix bon j'avoue bon tarf où là je
vais dire ce que tout le monde dit elle
depuis je suis né j'ai ça messieurs
quelque part ce n'est pas une preuve de
virilité
non je commente cette vidéo alors que
lucas ne lit pas les commentaires mais
détrompe toi je les lis depuis que j'ai
fait une vidéo sur youtube dauphin je
lis ce qu'ils soient au top donc les 100
premiers et ça me fais mes gars plaisir
vraiment ça m'avait manqué [ __ ] vous
m'aviez manqué watts est tellement beau
et viril d'arc robinet dunks robinet il
faut qu'on parle j'ai des doutes sur sa
sincérité
sinon on en parle que dans la
description le jeu et pong quoi youtube
youtube prenez votre robot là vous lui
mettez des petites claques comme ça
arrête de traquer les gens qui utilisent
du maître gims arrête de te bourrer dans
la détection des jeux alors passons à la
vidéo ce jeu explose ton cerveau à
souplesse niveau angle droit
voilà au début je croyais qu'il parlait
de l'écho au genre de savoie avec un
truc qui fonctionne avec son micro
mais je comprenais pas trop maintenant
un écho de soi même pourquoi je rentre
dans ce débat là qu'est ce qui m'arrive
depuis quand je vous ai plus
intelligents que nous qui a compris ce
jeu deux tares et là je suis pas du tout
plus intelligent que vous mais en vrai
les jeux comme ça tu peu compliqué à
cause du montage des fois c'est beaucoup
moins qu'au principe pour vous que pour
moi qui vit le truc vraiment vous voyez
qu'une sorte de best-of donc vous avez
moins de temps pour comprendre un
fichier avec cote est dans un jeu comme
ça c'est compliqué du coup deux suivants
c'est pour ça que les jeux comme ça qui
demande un petit peu de réflexion comme
est complexe et qui sont gratuits je
vous invite à télécharger à tester vous
même et complexe qu'est ce que c'est un
mot qui rime avec duplex corn flakes
voilà plus de rythme c'est trop
compliqué pour les rimes au début était
complexe
ouais il est chiant leurs petits au co
choix show pénale hainaut à la paris
games week et le mec parmi vous qui m'a
donné sa rhinopharyngite notre toit fdp
s'est bien occupée ton cas regardez mon
on peut faire de messages audio sur
youtube
voilà voilà ce qui se passe au tout
internet hors sujet squeeze j't'adore
des [ __ ] de vidéos à l'appui violence
gros bisous à toi je vais te dire que je
serai plus grands que toi notamment
l'infirmière du collège m'a dit que je
ferais un mètre 76 lol où elle m'avait
dit que je serais un mètre
quatre-vingt-cinq s'est bien trompé je
t'en veux madame dorénavant je t'en veux
je suis entre le plus haut et le ballon
a eu sa malle ok on passe à happy with
3d franchement tes blagues sont de mieux
en mieux mais pas ton art thou art au
graff goze angels and co
comme madoff a devancé de 17 heures le
mec sur la blague [ __ ] bien jouer
c'est gentil wargame vous devez mais je
dis bien vous devez mettre toutes les
vidéos de squeeze en vitesse 05 il
al'air bourré mais un point tel
aujourd'hui nous allons ensemble jouer
bas vraiment dit françois hollande
excellent j'adore tout cas c'est vrai
que jumbo est mort pas du tout il va
très très bien il torture autant ils
mangent toujours autant mais fait plus
de bêtises a de plus j'ai montré son
vrai visage dans une vidéo il fait moins
le malin
regardez là bas du lait on m'explique
ces [ __ ] de traces de croncels
font-elles de l'équipe hervé parent tout
ici ça bouffe est posée ici et la
dernière fois le paquet tu te reproche
quelque chose comment tu fais pour faire
une vidéo tous les deux jours tout en
ayant conduit pour faire vidéo tous les
d 2 2 jours j'avais à dire se désole un
vrai prêtre d'analphabétisme la limite
aux ressemblances 100% ressemblance avec
qui malcolm jesse pinkman acteur
américain très beau gosse une chèvre
c'est l'heure du bilan
c'est ce que je fais que mam un super
beau abonnez-vous à sa chaîne youtube
nom ne crée pas de gêne youtube qui
s'appelle la main dessus
vous êtes une des personnes les plus
vues sur le mettre dans le monde
bach des comme on peut le voir c'est
vraiment beaucoup mieux qu'avant ça
m'amuse de nouveaux énormément de lire
vos commentaires ça me fait super
plaisir franchement ça m'avait grave
manqué parce que comme je vous ai dit
faire des vidéos voire des vues des
trucs mais jamais voir de vrais messages
des gens des gens qui donnent leur avis
ou qui ont envie de se marrer que toi et
ses bas c'était un peu je me sentais un
peu vide est la péta je me sens plein et
c'est grâce à vous je vous remercie
vraiment du coup c'est validé c'est
validé par la prod c'est validé par
booba c'est validé par le comité de
validation des commentaires youtube et
merci beaucoup aux gens qui m'a renvoyé
plein de problèmes nice suite à ma vidéo
le fléau youtube pour me dire qu'il y
avait moyen de mettre des modérateurs
sur sa chaîne youtube des mecs qui ont
le pouvoir de supprimer les commentaires
tout comme toi du coup il ya une petite
armée de modérateur maintenant qui
rôdent dans l'espace commentaires et qui
supprime tout ce qui est hors sujet et
faire ce qu'on enterre lac etc
d'ailleurs vous pouvez maintenant
remarquer qu'en bas de la description
des vidéos il ya des règles voilà à
respecter dans l'espace commentaire
j'espère que vous êtes aussi content de
moi de voir que cet espace redevient
très très cool ça fait plaisir [ __ ] ça
ne m'avait vraiment manqué et puis comme
d'habitude je vous dis quoi attirer une
prochaine vidéo c'est par regarder
partez-vous biagio du bourde clé usb